[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  but no away from water and the water get  some water please  anybody what  [Music]  what game changes here so we know what  the deal is so when all these bombs  start walking Tony's always working I  [Music]  went to dig a spy bunker next to the  waterway so I can just go under the  ground where nobody's gonna expect it  because they're gonna be looking for  spikes then you're gonna be looking for  an underground bunker the best quality I  have for this game is actually what's  needed to win this game and that's  adaptability and they get fooled again  that's shame on them this game's not  worth if you lose I would never do  anybody a win  [Music]  [Music]